but you could see Tobin struggled with
the weight of the wheelbarrow at times
[Laughter]
you gotta do the rest of it
you're so cute
[Music]
yesterday we were talking about
something very similar to this article
but this is another one in this era of
serial killer Madness right like like
Julius serial killer you mean like the
regular nice guy hiker chamber romantic
slash serial killer date I don't know I
was like I was on the edge of my seat
thinking she's gonna get murdered you
spent a lot of time with him too how
many hours would you say you spent
um well I think it took us like an hour
and a half to get down the mountains you
know what's funny he probably went home
thinking you know we really hit it off
yeah I really yeah we that was I mean
when he sent me the photo on Instagram
we were like just chatting for a little
bit
[Music]
no but it wasn't really anything it was
just like hey cool it was nice to meet
you yeah nice meeting you too another
letdown I was waiting for that story to
be like yeah he tied my hands we should
show each other's hands it's going on
don't tip your mouth okay your contacts
watch another video all right here we go
Okay so
a woman once lived next door to a serial
killer
claims to know where his victims are
having recalled seeing him struggling
with a wheelbarrow containing waste
covered in tarp all right do you know
the story very similar did this
yesterday no because the other one was
this dude had his daughters do it this
is neighbor this is a neighbor this
guy's name is Peter Tobin I gotta show
this photo where is this you know we all
need to collectively start getting these
images of Serial colors uh Killers to
see if we can like kind of profile a
pattern Typecast them you know what I
mean she called it because they called
it it was a white guy is he white yeah
okay he's white I think he looks Italian
he does kind of look like he makes pasta
he's spicy white spicy spicy I like it
what's Toby mysterious white Tobin last
name Tobin Peter Tobin sounds sounds
pretty 31.2 yeah there it is okay why do
serial killers have like the dopest
names [ __ ] Dahmer Dahmer Bundy Ted
bonds Bundy and who's never known anyone
else with those last names because you
would think they would have names where
you're like oh no wonder he's a serial
killer like manslaughter yeah like no
like they're like you know night killer
yeah because that's that's the
connection names Hannibal Lecter no no
like like they got a weak name we gotta
we like your name I think he's the real
guy but you got cool names it you got
cool names I'm trying to make a point
that if he had a weird name that they
would be making fun of him and then he
turned into a serial killer ah
you know somebody I remember seeing
somebody using astrology as a way to
figure out who's a celery serial killer
oh my God yeah because that's factual
yeah yeah I have no idea but I forgot
which one it was they either said
Capricorn or Sagittarius I'm Sagittarius
you're a serial killer makes a lot of
sense no yeah I don't know don't call me
on it but there was one that's more
prominent is it because the Zodiac
Killer and they went maybe we should
have just looked into his horoscope they
were just looking at their birth charts
from every serial killer that that was
like recorded and there was like a large
amount in one one there's something
interesting high probability of
Capricorns out there that are killing
people huh I don't know which one I
don't know so Peter Tobin who I don't
know what his [ __ ] zodiac sign is was
serving a life sentence uh in Edinburgh
when he died of cancer at the age of 76
the dude's already dead all right wow
earlier this month have you been
connected in 2007 of murdering Angelica
cluck age 23 Vicki Hamilton age 15 and
dynamic Nicole age 18. he's already been
convicted did emerging those why they
like killing girls all the time well I
mean come on yeah see was that I feel
like guys will be just a headache like
dude [ __ ] Sagittarius
oh [ __ ] they would Crack the Code but I
thought that his list of potential
victims is much higher with his record
including burglary forgery and
uh now a woman who used to live next
door to Tobin has recalled seeing him
dispose of waste claiming she knows
where he buried other victims wow
another photo that we just wanna we
wanna humanize this guy see that's why I
don't want Nate I don't want neighbors I
don't how do you get though how do you
how does this guy trick a girl to go
with it yo those eyebrows are crazy I
can't put my groceries in the car real
quick and then snatch [ __ ] well he does
uh it is a little chilling I think the
way that he constantly has an answer
ready when somebody questions like what
are you doing like late at night with a
wheelbarrow you know I mean he's always
got like a different go-to answer oh
Christmas presents live next door
recalled team dispose of the waste
claiming she knows where some other
victims were starting early and uh she
said she's always out late often at
about 11 30 p.m we'd hear him before
we'd see him the haunting squeal of his
wobbling wheelbarrow and shuffling steps
along the Alleyways she's an author by
the way no I'm just kidding I know she's
good is so descriptive I feel like I was
there she explains how he's will be able
to transport waste to a nearby garage
and a cabbage field saying the suspects
of other human remains may be found at
these sites having alerted police about
suspicious activities near his then home
the neighbor continues there was an
alley that led from his back Garden via
a gate to empty garages it was just a
few minutes walk but you could see Tobin
struggled with the weight of the
wheelbarrow at times wheelbarrel
[Laughter]
yeah we sometimes saw him typical
English you got to do the rest of the
day like that you're so cute
all the dark news some bands all the
dark news now has to be reported with
that that's so that's dark dude we want
baby talk we love it that's really good
it lightens the blow a little it does it
made the story feel more better like she
said one time that he would hunt over
hit the wheelbarrow
meticulously [ __ ] the pop anyways
engineer's the guy dogs start going
crazy barking and jumping towards the
wheelbarrow in an attempt to pounce on
whatever was beneath the tarp and her
friend asked Tobin what he was doing and
what was in his wheelbarrow uh wheel
bear well [ __ ] I can't do it now yeah I
can't save heroin I [ __ ] can't say so
the dog was trying to grab like a limb
or something like just barking at it
because like you know it's obviously
every dog's a cadaver dog right he's
like mark bark bark there's a dead body
in there
you [ __ ] human see what I'm seeing
you look at idiots at this point you
know when when he's questioned which is
a okay excuse he says I'm getting rid of
some mud from uh from my garden and
picking up some hardcore for the
swimming pool because he was he was
telling his neighbors he's building a
swimming pool right um and he never
built it dude my neighbor I don't know
this was scaring me my name is all right
talk about it let's talk about it does
he also have a no you don't hear
something crazy yeah he [ __ ]
like even in the summer he'll like burnt
from the chimney he's like burning
things and we're like why is it does it
smell weird that's the thing is the
smoke black it smells like a human
barbecue
it smells like feet this is like burnt
feet no but it does have like a weird
smell like a I don't know it just has
like like a like a musty smell just like
coming out is there anything you compare
it to like uh like rotten wood
it's like like a strong scent of wood
that's just like rotten it's just like
pungent you're like oh
all year round I understand he does it
all year round every once in a while
he'll start like burning things and I'm
just like why but why would you say it's
like a charcoal-like smell mixed with
sulfurous odor well dude that's way too
descriptive and I don't know sulfur
sulfur smells like uh raw eggs yeah
rotten eggs
um I want to say like it smells like you
just said rotten wood why wood yeah
sulfur like a rotten wood like it smells
like wood like moldy molded wood the
wood like just like this has burning
skin has a charcoal like smell yeah okay
while uh while setting hair on fire
produces a sulfurous odor I don't know
dude but he's very with the reason why
is that he did the wheelbarrow thing and
has like a blue tarp on it and he does
this like blue Tarpon you better start
investigating my boy it's kind of like
this is [ __ ] kind of weird hey you
better start investigating he's very
quiet very weird and he wears like
overalls like he's like oh dude
JK Adventure we go to [ __ ] Jesus's
house I'm gonna [ __ ] do a Stakeout
you guys over there talking to the
neighborhood like dad knows your
neighbor here or yeah here here yeah
yeah well that's that's a little bit
it's weird right now right now when
you're saying everything the whole time
I'm thinking like huh
keep an eye out man I'm gonna keep an
eye I'm gonna record it and send you
guys videos put on your story like a
little investigation ever so you guys
videos updates yeah updates on the
neighborhood get some ring cameras out
getting weird you got a ring camera at
your house so he's a little he's a
little weird guy he's very quiet he
tried talking to him and he just you
should ask him hey so what are you
burning no I was gonna but then I feel
like that's he's gonna trigger him why
are you watching me yeah but who cares
because you're my neighbor and I see it
right there so you know who cares what
he says just see what he's gonna say to
your question
um
try to pry some information you could
get killed afterwards but like that's
what I'm saying cool listen it's it's
like fate anyway so yeah I like how the
white people were the ones that are like
what's going on what's happening what's
happening I'm just like hey Latino's
like yeah
do your thing on me hey don't be good
bro it was so weird though it was going
on homie did your date on me a white
person's just like hi what's going on
over there what are you guys having
that's fun it's like you never invite us
to her barbecue what's going on you're
always burning things it's crazy it
smells weird what's going on it smells
great and US yeah you're just [ __ ]
hey what's how long you lived there for
for like two years now and he does it
all year round all your like every once
in a while but then in the summer is
when I noticed it because I'm like why
it's hot why burning things in your
chimney because he's killing people and
I was telling people like why is he and
they're just like I don't know who cares
and I'm like what do you mean who cares
something's up if you ever [ __ ] find
out what's going on over there break the
news here yeah yes I'm gonna come here
dude you guys gonna put me on that black
thing with the weird voice
it's not too dim you can barely see me
you know and it's like you can see the
face we know it's you I'm still like hey
thanks Jesus for sharing your story at
the end it's like we need Joe to make
the Jingle the jingle of where it's like
oh it's like an emergency oh dude update
for sure
I'll send you guys an update when I see
it watch I'm gonna record it and see you
guys all right exclusive content you
better ask him though you better be like
hey what's up what's the next time he
burns something just [ __ ]
start recording dude start recording and
not going to record the chimney and
stuff and I'm gonna put the the [ __ ]
uh X-Files song we're like news just
broke there's smoke coming out of a
chimney yeah
I can never say that word the
wheelbarrow but I'm afraid I'm gonna say
something and then he's gonna have a
cool answer about it like you know I'm
like why are you burning and I let all
my things down then you just like made
me [ __ ] realize that's like too
because I don't have AC and I'm boring
[ __ ] like oh cause I thought you were oh
man we thought you were killing people
sorry dude yeah
[Music]